hey guys listening Antenor here from
Mohammed Smith Apollo in West London
where we've just been hands on the UK
premiere with Nintendo's switch urban
hands-on with Nintendo's brand new
console here to bring you our first
immediate impressions a term overall
overall I'd I liked what what I played
of it it felt it felt good to have a
really powerful portable console in my
hand which is like I know I don't play
very many iPad games and a lot of people
out there would be like oh I've had
really powerful but you know I found
doesn't have a Mario Kart iPad doesn't
have a Legend of Zelda iPad doesn't have
a splatoon so like that was exciting in
terms of like holding it in my hand yeah
it was heavier than I imagined it to me
like I thought it would be I think the
thing is there are a lot of
configurations you can do so which
configuration so I had it with the joy
concert cash for the screen so how you
would be playing it if you were taking
it out and about it was a little heavier
than I expected it to be for not not so
like they felt like flimsy or frail like
having like a 10-inch iPad it's a little
heavier than a Kennedy iPads I turn on
the iPad Air's now and those are quite
light yeah like you felt I felt like
good it felt good in my hand and part of
that is like it's weighted by the
security stuff but they've got like
clamp to it but like it wasn't it wasn't
cumbersome it it felt like I could put
that in my very large pocket or my bag
or whatever it may be without too much
hassle stability really good I found
like
it's not as like amazing it's like we're
not gonna blow you away like a Retina
screen dated like the first time you see
it but like if everything on there look
vibrant it'd look really really like
colorful and nice to look at bright
which is always good like it's got touch
screen stuff apparently but we didn't
get to see any of that but yeah it was
just really nice to be playing a Mario
Kart in the palm of my hand
similar with Zelda yeah it's a really
nice screen I think we can also use the
drug funds as basically they're very
small yeah to lose them yeah I have a
really awful feeling because they are
like they're very they're very light
like the Apple TV remote but you know I
felt I felt like they were lower sponsor
yeah when it comes to motion yeah I
personally felt like I was holding too
much of it yeah it was when I were using
it like in it like very cool form as if
it was a Wii Wii controller I could
never find a comfortable grip on it
because the buttons are there's a lot of
buns on that thing like of different
sizes say like in the configuration yeah
so the cross d-pad day everyone's use
clear is gone instead of you go up
you've got buns which is a little
confusing and a little like just a bit
against what you're what you've been
trained to feel there for a long time
but it's not
it's finite field it's very strange so
how to controller like this where
certain configurations feel better than
others yeah yeah I think the buttons are
clicky they're quite clicky but that's
not an issue - I feel like a little more
difficult to press yeah the analog
sticks there like you said offset they
feel quite similar to like the PS Vita
ones where like they're very load to the
actual controller and they're very eager
to snap back into the middle so if you
do like micro adjustments quite letting
go of the stick like if you're a monster
on a player or something like that it
might it might you might find that
you've got you know control where it's
going a little more
pick it up and take it to another Fang
and put it down so you know jury's still
out on how that works yeah I had an
issue with this is gonna sound weird but
the vibration it's not very powerful so
I was playing Zelda and you know like
mountains are coming out of the ground
anything you just felt like I had a
mobile phone in my bag like it felt that
kind of you know weak sort of vibration
you said if I give the vibration the
reason you bring that up is because they
made a big deal of it during the stream
you know they had someone holding a
glass and pouring ice cubes into it and
showing you how it feels natural but
when we played it in the in a kind of
like tablet form with the joy ponds on
the side it felt very weak it just felt
like I was getting a bit of vibration on
the other palm not very there's not a
fidelity or start with you on nuance to
it and similar with what you said with
Zelda and splatoon's very similar as
well but there is a game here where you
have to kind of like figure out where
the ball bearings are run in a little
like container based on the movement of
it and it felt quite good there so maybe
it's like when it's just in its like you
know joy Quan remote yeah
[Music]
[Music]
the only other game that kind of is a
big deal here is platoon two and that
very similar looks good plays well more
splatoon
anyway terrible jokes an infection of
the switch and its launch lineup call
the games coming out hunters make sure
you stay tuned to games.com
[Music]